we're living the Platinum life the
Platinum life star nozzoli mandy opens
up about her upcoming wedding to Grammy
award-winning singer Miguel and
launching a music career of her own we
see you in one of the promo shots in the
studio yeah yeah yeah so is there going
to be music coming from matheny yes yes
so you will see me on the show and get
back into music okay I stopped a few
years ago I became very very fearful and
yeah and you'll see it I talked about it
my address my anxiety mm-hmm which is a
very personal issue but I'm not afraid
to talk about it because a lot of people
deal with things I definitely and they
don't talk about it and it's time that
we do and you have a platform absolutely
able to do that absolutely thank you no
I mean it's it's true in Israel yeah you
know we're all dealing with something no
one is perfect you will see my struggle
with my anxiety on the show you'll see
my struggle with being a perfectionist
you know yeah no one's perfect and I
have to come to that conclusion but that
all ties in with my music and Miguel
obviously being a Grammy Award winner
yeah does he help you with that yeah he
actually wrote my EP that we're putting
out Wow yeah and produce you'll see us
in the studio working which is amazing
that's so fast and my EP will be out
probably end of November oh there we go
yes with videos and everything oh yeah
we're doing it I mean I have no choice
yeah you gotta get it go it's on the
show so I can't you know back out of me
no he's gotta hit the ground running
girl so we're going for it Congrats
that's so cool thank you so any duets on
the album no no no you might hear some
of his vocals in there yeah and then I
do background vocals actually on his new
album that's coming out
you'll definitely bet this power couple
over here being HT Miguel is fun as look
at this ring you guys she's about to be
a missus I am are you ready yes I've
been ready for one time you guys have
been on and off for like 11 11 years
yeah yeah we at one point we broke up
for one year Wow yeah okay it one year
straight yeah yeah hang yourselves out
and absolutely figure it out you grow
and it was very difficult very very
difficult but you're at now yeah you
know have you picked out a dress no you
haven't no we see you on the show and
the dressing like I have to ask about
the dress no no you know that was like a
first for me it was the first time I
ever tried on a wedding dress you guys
will see my reaction what's awesome and
it's very very genuine and it was very
it was a very emotional experience what
are your top three must-haves for your
guys away oh good music good food you
know that's all we need we we could be
anywhere and if we have those three
things and our family of course we're
good
do you think you guys will have a lavish
wedding or more of a laid-back
definitely lavish yeah yeah your version
right yeah I'm half Persian yes so I
kind of have no choice my best friend's
Persian OC parties yeah but that's
really our personality too we have some
questions hang on real quick okay so
Chris is asking love you and Miguel
together how romantic is he he's very
romantic yeah yes extremely what's the
most romantic thing he's ever done he
writes songs I mean to me that's like
the most romantic thing yes for sure
yeah I mean I'd rather have that than
anything else yeah
[Music]